you know when we talk about Republicans
claiming to have principles and then
completely ignoring those principles it
often is when it comes to things like
economics oh the debt and deficit we
really only care about that when the
president's a Democrat all right I
gotcha or uh you know business
regulation we don't want to regulate
business until it becomes inconvenient
then we want to regulate business but
even with these so-called culture War
social issues these are the absolute
biggest Hypocrites it turns out that
anti-drag everything she's against drag
shows drag queens drag Kings everything
Marjorie Taylor green
has a boyfriend he's the guy from right
side broadcasting network I know and uh
it turns out he is dressed in Drag
and of course she's defending him so
here's the video that has now been
Unearthed here is Brian Glenn in drag
saying he kind of likes wearing his
pantyhose take a look at this
I can tell you I I think a lot of people
up now they're all hashtag I am up of
course come and check it out here so I
saw them Saturday I'm kicking these
shoes off but I may keep the pantyhose
on it just feel kind of good actually
I'm not gonna pee in them I promise he
might might keep his panty hose on so
that's Brian Glenn in drag so of course
Marjorie Taylor green would denounce
this right because she's against this
she says this is grooming and this is
dangerous and it's obscene and no she
defends it Marjorie Taylor green taking
to Tweeter where she posted quote I'm
literally loling Brian Glenn dressed in
drag for Morning News in Dallas years
ago reporting on an upcoming local
theater production and the morons over
at Patriot takes think this is an attack
Brian loves the throwback and is
reposting laughing crying Emoji the left
is so stupid oh okay okay
we know that they are hypocrites on the
big issues that deficit business
regulation Etc but it seems like they
are truly Hypocrites about everything
even the social issues even the culture
War issues all of it does it matter why
you dress in drag now before it was oh
no no when men dress in drag it's
predatory and it's bad and it's grooming
and it's dangerous and all of these
different things now it's well no hold
on if you're dressing in drag to promote
a theater production then it's okay if
you dress and drag to I guess read
stories to kids that's what's bad it's
not the drag it's the fact that they're
doing it around children or whatever the
case may be these people are completely
and totally vapid there is nothing there
and they are hypocrites on every single
one of these issues Marjorie Taylor
green at the absolute top of the list I
know people keep writing to me saying
David you should really cover this
relationship with Brian Glenn because
Marjorie Taylor green claims to be a
Christian and sanctity of marriage and
all these different things it seems
almost like it's certain that she was
with this Brian Glenn Guy having an
affair even when she was still married
before she was separated and getting
guys I don't care yeah like obviously
I'm sure she's a hypocrite Lauren
bobert's now getting divorced even
though she said Christian people aren't
supposed to get divorced they stay
together you work through all these
different things they're Hypocrites
they're all Hypocrites I really don't
care about her personal life other than
the hypocrisy but even like the affair
uh all these people who preach the Bible
are having Affairs many of them not all
of them I want to be careful it's not
new but she is the same type of pathetic
hypocrite that we've been following for
a long time so there it is uh anti-drag
Marjorie Taylor Green's boyfriend in
drag in this particular particular case
it's fine one of our sponsors today is
Bond charge I have always enjoyed dry
saunas you get in there your heart rate
is up dilates the blood vessels can
soothe achy joints and muscles it's
relaxing it's just a great way to remove
a little stress Bon charge is the
creator of the infrared sauna blanket
which you can enjoy from home super easy
to set up heats up fast you don't have
to have your head inside like at a
traditional sauna at the gym nice for
meditating or reading getting work done
relaxing I have found it to be a great
way to unwind at the end of a long day
easy to clean Sleek lightweight design
easy to store and comes with a 12-month
warranty and of course if you don't love
it returns are super easy but I think
you will love it and you'll get 15 off
when you go to boncharge.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below